[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain an episode from an american
adult animated anthology love death and
robots called ice age
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
a young couple has just moved into their
brand new apartment the husband named
rob brings boxes of their belongings
into the house while his wife gail
places utensils in the kitchen
gail is bothered by an old fridge that
the landlord had kept in the apartment
they cannot get rid of it but it looks
hideous in the kitchen
rob tries to be optimistic and tells her
that old fridges have technology that
the new ones don't like the massive
motor it has on top of it
gail sarcastically says that it is
insane making fun of her husband's
geekiness tired after carrying all the
boxes she suggests they drink some wine
rob opens the old fridge to see if it
has some ice to his surprise he sees
thick chunks of ice covering the freezer
he gets a cube and puts it in his drink
they sit down and make a toast to their
new house
after taking a sip rob notices a strange
structure in the ice when rob realizes
what it is he doesn't seem to believe
his eyes he hands the cube to gail
asking her to confirm there's something
in it she brings out a magnifying glass
and the two look into it to see a tiny
mammoth frozen in the cube the two are
confused and surprised they notice that
the tiny creature was hunted because it
has spears in its side a confused gale
goes back to the freezer and removes
pieces of ice to finally reveal a tiny
working medieval civilization the time
inside the freezer seems to be passing
by faster as the people go about their
normal day in seconds the couple is
fascinated and baffled as to how this
can be possible the people inside do not
seem to care about large giants watching
them
some time later rob buries the mammoth's
tiny body under their house plant gail
makes fun of him and opens the freezer
again to see that the medieval time has
changed to the industrial revolution
while they were away for a few minutes
decades have gone by in the freezer they
watch people build tall buildings and
houses in seconds
rob is sad because he missed the
renaissance period and wonders if the
people inside the freezer think they are
gods just then two construction workers
from inside the freezer complain about
the two idiots who watch them every day
saying that they're tired of looking at
the broccoli in gail's teeth
in no time the industrial era changes
into the modern era and massive
skyscrapers are built tiny objects fly
over the buildings which rob is confused
about but gail suggests that they might
be airplanes the couple watches in
fascination as the time changes to the
present
rob laughs looking at a starbucks
building trying to relate to the tiny
world he moves closer to get a better
look when suddenly a massive bright
missile launches on the tiny city a
startled rob falls back to the kitchen
floor as gail tries to help him the
people inside the freezer are at war and
everything seems to be destroyed the
couple gets a look at humanity's harsh
future but doesn't seem to care
gail closes the refrigerator claiming
that the people cannot outgrow a war in
a few minutes so they should come back
later the two order a pizza and enjoy it
completely ignoring the nuclear war
happening inside their freezer
about an hour later rob suggests they
check what is going on inside the couple
seems to be afraid to open the freezer
fearing they would look at the
extinction of humans however they are
met with a pleasant surprise when they
finally open it the war has ended and
mankind has recovered from it they even
notice flying cars and compare the tiny
futuristic place to the emerald city
humans are more advanced than ever
before the futuristic world has several
skyscrapers connected with bridges in
the beginning but then a singular
pyramid-like structure takes over they
assume that everyone lives inside the
pyramid now when the pyramid unfolds it
reveals a diamond-shaped structure
inside the structure absorbs the whole
city and soon a sphere of energy forms
in the middle it finally bursts sending
sparks of energy flying into the
couple's kitchen they watch in
fascination as the sparks jump around
the room like fireflies they believe
that humans have unfolded every secret
of the universe and are now traveling
around space that is beyond their
expectations
then the sparks of light converge into
the sphere again and transfer into the
freezer which the couple assumes is
their true home
at last the sphere disappears presumably
indicating the end of the world the
couple watches the empty freezer in
confusion rob wonders if they are coming
back but gail claims that it is unlikely
rob finally unplugs the refrigerator and
the couple hug having witnessed the past
present and future of humanity in the
past few hours
it is now the following morning the two
wake up and continue with their morning
routine however the thought of last
evening hasn't left their minds they
decide to open the freezer for the last
time to check if everything is really
over to their utmost surprise the era of
dinosaurs has returned several tiny apes
eat the flesh from a dead dinosaur they
run away as another dinosaur attacks
them the episode ends as the couple
continues to watch the tiny creatures in
their natural habitat
this episode of love death and robots is
particularly famous for the interesting
concept of the whole creation evolution
and the end of mankind being shown in
miniscule measurements the concept of
both time and dimension is challenged by
a magical freezer it is only right to
call the freezer a natural phenomenon
because how it came into existence is
never explained in the short movie some
fans of the show believe that the fridge
belonged to the previous owners who were
tired of watching the fate of humanity
repeatedly so they left it in the house
before moving
the film also provides us hope for the
future because the world inside the
freezer recovered from the most
devastating war mankind had ever seen
however by watching rob and gail order
pizza and enjoy it while the little
world was at war we come across the
negligence of people and their
non-existent sense of responsibility
towards the problems of the world in
this short film we can witness a
possible future of humanity that doesn't
end in its extinction unlike the usual
devastating endings that most of the
movies predict ice age shows us the
possibility of humans figuring out the
universe and becoming one with it the
ball of energy formed in the
pyramid-like tower is most likely a
technology that allows them to escape
reality after finding out every secret
about our existence the ball of energy
disappeared into thin air indicating
that humans changed dimensions and have
become a higher being
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching